the year 2012 the problem birds are
congregating on the Texas Medical Center
campus and doing
bird things the solution attach Nets to
the large oak trees on campus forcing
Birds to take their business elsewhere
sounds like a great idea with the best
of intentions what could possibly go
wrong turns out birds eat bugs with the
birds gone the trees became a Haven for
cute furry looking Critters that happen
to be North America's most venomous
caterpillar contact with these toxic
misery Tribbles can cause intense
radiating pain vomiting fever
convulsions paralysis and even death
with netsup and apex predators gone
researchers determine the population of
these comb over paint Merchants
increased by a whopping 7 300 percent
bad news for anyone but especially a
vulnerable population seeking Health
Care at say oh I don't know a medical
center campus but you know what they say
flock around and find out